victoria's secret is getting rid of
the angels victoria's secret is getting
rid of all the hot chicks
and they're making a conscious decision
to trade the hot chicks
for megan repino that radical
purple-haired lesbian soccer player
and they're going to do this as a major
massive marketing turnaround to give
women what they really
want so this is the headline new york
times victoria's secret swaps
angels for what women want will they buy
this shows you
speaking of self-love and self-obsession
this shows you how mistaken this modern
ideology is
the embattled lingerie giant is
attempting the most extreme brand
turnaround in recent memory an effort to
redefine not just itself
but also the very idea of what sexy is
so so what i'm trying to be like polite
about this
victoria's secret is now going to say
that
what was that woman's name tara banks
you know she was like extremely
attractive
or all of the victoria's secret angels
they are no longer set they're going to
redefine sexy
so they are no longer sexy sexy is
megan repino sexy is
people who are not sexy
that's that's the that's the argument
even that the new york times is making
okay this is i guess just one of the
most
ridiculous examples of how the left
tries to
redefine the words in order to redefine
reality you might say they try to
control words to control minds which is
the subject of my upcoming book
speechless
available now for prayer just in case i
didn't know if the bill was going to
come in on time
just in case you can get that right now
that uh speechless i think is only oh my
gosh oh my
it's only available for pre-order for
another five days folks you can get
a signed first edition copy from
premiere collectibles for five more days
then it will no longer be on pre-order
it will be on order but they will not be
on pre-order anymore so go get
speechless today
you go to you can go to you can go to
speechlessbook.com
i'm going to double up on the pavlovian
responses so that that's their plan
they're going to
at victoria's secret get rid of the hot
angels and put in these people who are
not
not attractive they say this is what
women want
why do women buy victoria's secret do
they buy victoria's secret just for
themselves
no they buy victoria's secret for
me and for you other guy listening to
this show
and for you guy listening to this show
in your car
they buy victoria's secret to make
themselves
attractive to men there may be some
other reasons maybe it feels
more comfortable in certain ways but
really that's not it the purpose of
victoria's secret
is to be sexy right that's what new york
times is telling you they're redefining
what sexy is
it's to be sexy who are they sexy for
they're sexy for men
i know that today we're supposed to
pretend that ninety 90
of the population are like trans bi
non-binary lesbian what but that's just
not true
the overwhelming majority of people 97
or so are basically ordinary in their
sexual views
and for the vast vast majority of women
they're trying to attract men
and men are not attracted
how do i i don't want to be rude to
anybody men are attracted to people who
are sexy and what is sexy
is to to a very small degree socially
constructed
and to the much larger degree natural it
comes from our loins it comes from our
dna
it comes from our caveman brain and no
amount of social engineering is going to
change that
this victoria's secret story is the
whole story of progressive politics
they the progressive looks at the world
and says i hate this world i hate the
way society is i hate the way we live
i hate nature itself and i'm just going
to change it
and i can change that through my
unfettered reason and through my
tyranny of will in politics which can
turn the world into anything that i want
it to be
ye shall be as gods as the serpent
tells eve in the garden of eden as
whitaker chambers the ex-communist
describes communism as saying
it's it's the serpent in the garden you
shall be his gods but you shan't be you
really will not be
you can't totally change the world the
experiments in politics fail and i
strongly suspect the experiment from
victoria's secret is going to fail
too oh hey there oh hey sorry
i didn't see you there you should ring
the bell right now and
you should subscribe and make sure you
get the notifications and you should
also head on over
to the apple podcast and spotify and
google play and all that to subscribe to
the audio
oh you're probably yeah right this is my
upcoming book speechless controlling
words controlling minds
it's available now for pre-order but
it's coming out super duper soon so make
sure you pre-order your signed
autographed both it'll be both signed
and autographed
first edition copy at premiere
collectibles you can also get on amazon
barnes noble anywhere you get your books
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]